what is he doing well now you guys are
good
well maybe I don't know about that he
just stares at you makes it go really
yes I'm taking a nice radiation being
the tire is the best thing there we go
good this look at this Aaron what I'm
doing I can't look at this because I'm
sure it's all frozen willing to
introduce myself to them I want to get
off on the right foot to prop Co props
is Claire you'll be embarrassed I have
the memory of a fox is that a good yeah
what does it say I don't know I got the
schlong of a zebra
good job good for you oh I just kind of
like to make sure of that area you know
it's clean it's clean clear
clean clear oh hi there
[Laughter]
cuz I'm pretty sure that hmm
I let myself be found I was feeling kind
of bad to you this don't feel bad for us
so bad for yourself because you're dead
manners that's a good song fine wasn't
everything about plain slang Kenna oh is
he breaking the rules
he's noise he's following me oh oh how I
saw he's in here he's in here well he's
he's not exactly breaking the rules he's
kind of twisting a little bit because he
is in plain sight you just can't really
see him Oh cuz it's pitch black
exactly just watching your name's [ __ ]
well this is rude because we can't see
jack I've been guilty of hiding in this
stuff before for that very reason
I feel like good times
hmm yeah we literally if you're in there
I am not implying something right now
I'm not cheat I haven't cheated this
whole round I know what the shadows are
pretty invisible darkness just are you
Batman are you Batman
justice
[Music]
damnit
oh my god how long can you do that okay
so he's not he's not just no he's just
running around trolling us that's all he
does how have you not seen me well this
is quite the spectacle get out of the
darkness and the shadows and embarrassed
I can't tell your names I'll say I'm
gonna help addictions the closest right
now had enough of that [ __ ] mmm
Oh can't what you guys are doing a
really good job I'm just you know aside
from all of my heckling and and and rude
remarks you guys yeah yeah whatever
that's part of the heckling what you're
doing right now well see you guys I
can't get out of here apparently yeah
you can't go back there's a human whoops
well that was fun I'm glad we had a good
time together oh my god what was he I
cannot reveal my that again that's not
nice fun wasn't though it was it I was
thoroughly entertained with the
performance oh my god I'm so glad you
guys invited me to play this today this
is nice
well we're never fighting you again
invitation not extended your way mark
are you really what he was in there for
like an entire 30 second period looking
right at him but I'm watching you wait
he's not anymore he's better now
okay now he's cheating
man move why can't I not move in second
wait a second somebody something over
here was red I saw are you cheating
right now no I'm not I mean if I were I
can't move still I'm not cheating I just
can't move I can't the hell wide my
thing turned red then I'm stuck so stuck
okay so how do we play you begin the
short end of the stick that's that's
that's that's gonna get top-up boats on
reddit and [ __ ] you know oh yeah up
boats for days all right let's see if we
can do this again now all right no
pressure I am somewhere that they will
struggle torture room he said struggle
see making a pun he's already please
already following us around I can
guarantee I know you all too well some
things I wish I didn't know oh yeah you
waste well what the fungus like you
shoot into the dark spaces that it
doesn't
[Music]
he's following us
hey guys how's it going yeah follow me
follow me let's get to props
I feel like we should you though hmm
[Music]
they must have been in the same spot and
he just got away must have fed he has a
habit of doing that I got eyes on are
you you're gonna be the put your eyes on
okay so you're gonna see you five
percent yeah I got this Ariane so in
other words all you can really do is
look and you're nice yes that's all I
can do I got nothing so leave me be the
skies and wire yet what are you giggling
about you laughing at me I see nothing
don't laugh at the poor man he's only
you know got 5% health he basically has
cancer right now and you're laughing
I didn't know what an alarm sound I made
but I didn't have a grenade left or else
I would have destroyed him there is he
here was a blue hand oh he went bright a
great little can little little blue can
okay
I saw hate this dark area cuz I know he
can just hide there and I'm never seeing
it
little blue can stop making fun of us on
again if I see him Oh ring the alarm
tell us which direction he goes yes he
went right at me that's the thing he
went right under me and disappeared
disappeared disappeared okay I'm not
sure I share your sentiment seconds can
you just can you just make a run at us I
do know where he was in the corner the
whole time I don't oh [ __ ] okay I gotta
go guys I get some lunch
well you got one more round to go yeah
one more round to go one more round
mm-hmm oh man I
royally [ __ ] to get a good spot so
shop the 9th at subtleness every
I've gone in the son of another side
sure they have learned from that mistake
stop this round out you want to do over
I can't boo would you like me to help
bunny
that's just holy oh my god that's so yes
I'm in plain sight as per the rules yeah
that's what he does it's what I do it's
all I do it works he is pretty good at
playing set yes I am it's down to this
game again I know what he does it's
gonna be do i do what do i do big object
yes sir what do i do keep screaming
you'll change objects faster I can't
are they even shooting you what do we do
cb4 fiying spectacle the man gone insane
fine fine fine
I'm done I'm
[Laughter]
fascinating
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]